[Musique]
le remplacer monsieur cap assistant dans
quelques semaines je vous demanderai de
l'accueillir avec bienveillance et
gentillesse comme vous savez le père les
élèves de la troisième un tout année là
mais en moyenne de l'académie c'est
qu'elle est juste que vous avez j'ai 40
ans mais du coup pourquoi est-ce que
vous êtes encore suppléant
je vous demanderais d'être
particulièrement attentifs le requin
on regarde ce qu'ils ont répondu à 88
quel métier voudriez vous exercez
manutentionnaire hôtesse de caisse femme
de chambre professeur suppléant tiens
c'est pour toi c'est dans ta gueule
allô allô a déjà eu des problèmes
ils ont toujours été très proches très
solidaire
c'était un dossier touche comprennent ça
vient tester leurs limites
qu'est ce que vous préparez
voulez-vous quelque chose dans votre vie
pour combler un vide
c'est nul on travaille là
qu au fatah fallait pas voir la vérité
en face
[Musique]
vous êtes vous savez